at her political rallies senator
Elizabeth Warren enters to the song
nine-to-five that's true that's true
yeah yeah I mean while at his political
rallies Bernie Sanders answers to the
song I'm 95 hey I'm Danny and you go hit
chances alone
this is my bernie sanders yeah I'm
working on it
Papa John's has named its new CEO and
they are all been wondering about that
one Papa John's has named its new CEO
it's the former president of Arby's yeah
yeah the former head of our be said I'm
excited to finally work in the food
industry
so just wants to see what it's like well
this is the latest on man this is insane
the president of Brazil is refusing to
put out the fire in the Amazon unless
the president of France apologizes for
calling him a liar yeah
but assuming I don't know about you but
I am ready for women to run the world I
really am
that is the kind of [ __ ] only men
get into I'll put out the Wildfire
that's destroying the world when you
apologize I know I know that's what Andy
and I get into before the show I'm not
going out until he goes out is he there
yet